que je vienne demain matin à 7 heures au
boulot oui voilà j'espère que ça ne te
dérange pas non non non non non ça ça me
nous sommes dérange pas vous savez je
suis je suis du matin moi me lever tôt
j'adore ta mère je compte sur toi
à demain voilà au revoir à demain
blaireau tu vas mal à raccrocher le
téléphone un des blaireaux chez moi hop
allez ouste sa bête allez vous en ouste
sales bêtes de béraut à la vie en
entreprise assez génial d'avoir des
collègues relou des patrons dictateur à
mi temps le lucky quoi je suis pas fait
pour la vie en entreprise je suis nul en
patron je sais pas comment m'y prendre
je sais pas si je dois à tutoyer vous
voyez mon patron par exemple si je le
tutoie et qu'il faut pas je suis fichée
dit que vous voyez qu'il faut pas je
suis fichée aussi alors j'ai trouvé une
astuce
le tu dis rien au jour cyprien ça va oui
ça va et j'imagine que ça va oui ça va
merci bonne journée des années
d'entraînement d'ailleurs en parlant de
patron je ne sais pas si tous les boeufs
ou comme ça mais si c'est le cas ou est
ce qu'ils ont trouvé leur humour
l'humour de patron 1 c'est peut-être que
tout qui fait le moins rire sur terre
derrière la chasse des bébés phoques qui
ça fait rire ça bah alors cyprien on est
parti plus tôt hier soir ah oui en fait
je devais aller chercher ma vie mais je
vais devoir vous virer comme ça vous
serez encore plus tôt chez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oh
et ben non ça va super drôle
après il ya différents types de patrons
bon moi par exemple je connaissais pas
dans le film comment tuer son boss
il parle des patrons nymphomane avec
jennifer aniston
[Musique]
moi je donne de l'argent pour avoir un
boss comme ça à l âne double de mon âge
elle pourrait être ma mère je je m'en
fous jennifer embauche moi je suis ton
objets faits moi faire ce que tu veux
des trucs interdits par la loi si tu
veux oui je viens trop joindre aux états
unis d'accord c'est passé par là bas ça
mais finalement je crois je crois que le
pire c'est c'est être stagiaire
vous pensiez quatre stagiaires
c'est enrichissant professionnellement
ou au où vous êtes mignon dans la
pyramide de la reconnaissance on a les
esclaves puis les insectes et enfin les
dictateurs et en dessous les stagiaires
non mais non mais sérieux quoi les
stagiaires on leur demande que des
tâches ingrates des tâches inhumaines
force qu'on m'a demandé stagiaires la
cible bien tu peux me caler un truc
le seigneur des anneaux la trilogie
recto verso
il fait ça vite tu vois les cartons là
bas c'est les archives des dix dernières
années
tu peux enlever toutes les agrafes avec
tes ongles on va mettre des trombones à
la place où là sont supers salle mes
lunettes tu peux me les nettoyer avec ta
langue surtout les croûtes sur les
branches là alors tout le monde vous le
dira le mieux c'est d'être son propre
patron
c'est bien une phrase toute faite ça
être son propre patron
ça ne veut rien dire 1 on peut pas être
son patron et son employé on peut mettre
les deux en même temps
sauf si tu est schizophrène moi tu peut
m'apporter un café s'il te plaît oui pas
de problème
tenez merci il est vraiment très bon sa
batterie lui changer de marque a changé
de marque un très beau ni sétif
oui sinon une petite marque comme ça de
café d'un mini piscine hop et en use
aussi sont les américains chérie chéri
je crois que le voisin est rentré de
l'hôpital ditan fellini nos chapelles
australien oui après les stagiaires
stagiaires oui est ce que tu peux venir
pour la réunion c'est le boss qui
t'appelle d'accord pas de problème merci
d'être aussi nombreux sur ma page
facebook et retrouver toute notre vie
sur son site pmu.fr c'est vrai ça part
mal l'écoutent
je n'aurais vallée